the things you were able to do in
tracking down information and we'll get
to it there's some suspicion that this
was only possible with mass surveillance
like with NSA for example uh first of
all is there any truth to that and
second of all what do you feel are the
pros and cons of mass surveillance
there is no truth to that and then my
feelings on mass surveillance if there
was would you tell me probably not but
I love this conversation so much but
what do you feel about
the given that you said child porn
what are the pros and cons of
surveillance at a society level
I mean nobody wants to give up their
privacy I say that I say no one wants to
give up their privacy but I mean I used
to have to get a search warrant to look
inside your house yeah or I can just log
on to your Facebook and you've got
pictures of all inside your house and
what's going on I mean it's not you know
so people like the idea of not giving up
their privacy
um but they do it anyways they're giving
away their freedoms all the time they're
they're carrying watches that gives out
their heartbeat a weight of companies
that are storing that I mean what's more
personal than your heartbeat so I I
think people
and mass really want to protect their
privacy and I would say most people
don't really need to protect their
privacy but the case against Mass
surveillance is that if you want to
criticize the government
in a very difficult time you should be
able to do it
so when you need the freedom you should
have it so when you wake up one day and
realize there's something going wrong
wrong with the country I love I want to
be able to uh to help the one of the
great things about the United States of
America is there's that individual
revolutionary Spirit like so that the
the government doesn't become too
powerful you can always protest there's
always the best of the ideal of freedom
of speech you can always say [ __ ] you to
the man and I think there's a concern of
direct or indirect suppression of that
through Mass surveillance you might not
is that that little subtle fear that
grows with time that uh why you know why
bother criticizing the government it's
going to be a headache I'm going to get
a ticket every time I say something bad
that kind of thing so it gets out you
can get out of hand the bureaucracy
grows and the freedom slip away because
that's the that's the criticism right I
completely see your point I agree with
it I mean but I mean on the other side
people criticize the government of these
freedoms but I mean tech companies are
talking about destroying your privacy
and controlling what you can say I
realize they're private platforms and
you they can decide what's on their
platform
um but you know they're taking away your
freedoms of what you can say and we've
heard certain some things where maybe
government officials were in line with
uh with tech companies to take away some
of that freedom and that's I agree with
you that gets scary yeah there's
something about government that feels
maybe because of the history of human
civilization maybe because tech
companies are a new thing but just
knowing the history of abuses of
government
if there's something about government
that enables the corrupting nature of
power to take hold at scale more than
tech companies at least what we've seen
so far
yeah I agree I agree but I mean we
haven't had a voice like we've had until
recently I mean anyone that has a
Twitter account now can speak and become
a news article
um you know my parents didn't have that
didn't have that voice if they wanted to
speak out against the government or do
something they had to go to a protester
organize a protester you know do
something along those lines so you know
we have more of a place to put our voice
out now yeah it's incredible but that's
why it hurts and that's why you notice
it when certain voices get removed the
president of the United States of
America was removed from one such or all
such platforms
and that hurts yeah that's crazy to me
that's insane that's insane that we we
took that away but